بشان العقوبات المفروضه على روسيا نشرت
لجنه الاستخبارات في مجلس النواب الامريكي
تقييما سريا الى مكتب مديره الاستخبارات
الوطنيه يفيد بان الصيني تساعد روسيا في
تجنب العقوبات الغربيه المفروضه عليها
وانها اصبحت شريكه اقتصاديا اكثر اهميه
لروسيا منذ غزوها لاوكرانيا وبحسب التقييم
الاستخباريه الذي رفعت السري عنه فان
الصين تسعى لخلق عده اليات دعم اقتصادي
لروسيا قد تخفف من تداعيات العقوبات
الغربيه والقيود على التصدير كما بين
الترقيم الاستخباريين الصين زادت من
استيراد صادرات الطاقه الروسيه بما في ذلك
موارد النفط والغاز ويوضح التقييم ان
الصين زادت من استخدام عملتها اليوم
وبنيتها التحتيه الماليه في تعاملات
التجاريه مع روسيا مما يسمح لكيانات روسيه
بالمضيف في تعاملات الماليه دون منع غربي
ونجحت القيمه الاستخباري الامريكي ان
الصين تقدم لروسيا تقنيه ذات استخدام
ثنائي وعسكري لتستخدم في اوكرانيا